à doha trop atteindre la cime des arbres
en quelques secondes
c'est désormais possible avec le benji
éjection bien harnachés au baudriller
les participants sont éjectés dans les
airs à l'aide de deux élastiques pour 8
euros sensations fortes garanties
on sent se sont propulsés vers le haut
nous a fait une sensation un peu comment
les parcs d'attractions quand on descend
mais là et on se fait propulser vers le
haut et quand on arrive au point
culminant et qu'on amorce la descente
voilà on a vraiment une sensation par
ailleurs similaire aux montagnes russes
depuis l'ouverture une soixantaine de
curieux se sont essayés au saut à
l'élastique inversée dans les airs
toutes les figures sont permises et si
l'activité en effraie plus d'un
tous sont satisfaits de sauter le pas
alors départ il ya une certaine
appréhension surtout quand on regarde la
personne passait avant soit ensuite
quand se faire lyncher
c'est à dire un peu plus dur parce qu'on
est dans l'inconnu si la personne n'a
jamais fait et ensuite comme l'a dit
simon
quand vous y êtes vous n'avez plus le
choix l'animation vise un public large
seules contraintes pesant entre trente
et cent dix kilos et avoir minimum 6 ans
au sud de l'île dans l'esprit du jeu
vidéo et proposer une autre activité
nouvelle
l'airsoft on a des obstacles avec des
cibles on les touche autant de fois
qu'on veut on a une centaine de billes
pour s'amuser le plus rapidement
possible donc voilà avec heures avec les
répliques
ça s'adresse à un public plutôt large en
général en revanche pardon il faut avoir
plus de 18 ans voilà ça c'est la loi
on ne peut pas mettre de répliques dans
les mains d'une personne mineure
pour le moment seul un parcours existe
mais en deuxième est en cours de
création
celui-ci favorisera les jeux de rôles
pour apprécier à plusieurs cette
nouvelle activité de l'île de loisirs